Mình bố thành chính, các quan an ninh của gia bà lăng cho biết
Tổng thống như này ông Carol Norokki đã khi thỏa thành cho phép mình lính của tổ chức
Hẹp ước mắt đại tây dương nát頭, luôn chú tại bà lăng
Hẹn dịt như một sự tăng cường của sự ữ cho của gia Trung Waú trong khuôn khổ chính
Rui của sự linh gác phía đông
Bà lăng là của gia có chung được viên giỏi dài hai trăm bà miệng 2 kilomét
Giá bởi vì vùng kali niên gác của ngàn
Hẹn mắt sức và trở có phản ứng chính thức về thục tin trên
Trước đó, tổng thức khi nào tôi mắt lúc tây hôm 12h,
Linh Minh đã kởi đọc trên dưới quân sự trên
Nằm tăng cường phòng thu, sân phía đông, sau sự cô thêm bị bài không người lại
UAV bị bàn hạ ở bà lăng
Một ngoài dòng ngà khi đó đã liên tiền bác bỏ các cảo buộc của bà lăng
Khẳng định, Más Cơ Và không liên quan tới vụ việc UAV xâm phạm không phận nước này
Tổng thống mi đô đăng trăm gần đây trong một bình luật
Cũng cho rằng sự việc UAV xâm phạm lại thuộc bà lăng
Có thể chỉ là nhằm lẫn